Transcriber: Hüseyin ÖZKAY
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Benim yaşantımda geriye bakmak yok.
Yaptığımız şeylerle ilgili bir şeyler
biriktirmek gibi birşeyler yapmadım ama
burada arkadaşları dinleyince
aklıma bazı hikâyeler geldi.
O hikâyelerden de bahsedeceğim.
Şöyle de bir ikilem yaşadım.
Biz akademisyenlerde bir şey var;
akademik ağırlıklı bir konuşma mı yapayım
yoksa bir TED konuşması mı yapayım diye.
Aslında karar veremedim.
Yurt dışından gelen kızım var.
Baba Allah aşkına akademisyen gibi
konuş referans ver falan diye
biraz da o baskı yaratttı bende.
Durumu idare edin. Ortaya karışık yapıcam.
Şöyle Eğitime %100 Desteğe bakarken birgün
rahmetli Kadir Has aradı beni.
1 trilyon vereyim de dedi
4 tane okul yap dedi.
Bende dedim ki
ya kusura bakmayın Kadir Bey
1 trilyona 4 tane okul yapılmaz.
Şunu biraz artırsanız falan dedim.
Ya dedi benim bütçem bellidir
30 trilyon Kayseri'ye harcıyacağım.
1 trilyon arttı onu da sana
vereyim yap falan.
Hem dedi ne konuşup duruyorsun,
ben istersem Cumhurbaşkanıyla
konuşurum dedi.
Sen kim oluyorsun diyor yani.
Ben dedim haklısınız, konuşursunuz.
Siz dedim eğitim hayırseverisiniz,
bir gün Allah gecinden versin
emri hak vaki olunca öleceksiniz
amma çürümeyeceksiniz dedim.
Tamam tamam dedi. Telefonu kapattı.
Birkaç dakika sonra Kurtul Altuğ aradı.
Ya Kadir Bey'le bir şey
konuşmuşsunuz dedi.
Ben onun biyografisini
yazıyorum. Aslında dedi
ne dediğinizi tam anlamamış
ama laf hoşuna gitmiş dedi.
Ne dediniz dedi.
Ya aslında ben dedim bir şey demedim.
Neşet (Ertaş)in sözünü eğitime
uyarlamaya çalıştım dedim.
"Güzel seven ölür ölür ama çürümez."
Ben onu eğitim hayırseveri ölür
ama çürümeze uyarlamaya çalıştım dedim.
Sonra Kadir Bey ertesi gün
oğlunu, Nuri Bey'i gönderdi.
Parayı 1.5 trilyona çıkarttı.
Bende ona dört tane okul yaptırdım.
Türkiye'nin en çok ihtiyacı olan yerlerin
listesi vardı elimizde.
Ona göre bir okul yaptırıyorduk.
Ben görevi bıraktığımda
Eğitime %100 Destek'te
2 milyar dolar para biriktirmiştik.
Ya da 2 milyar dolarlık
okul yapmıştık.
Temel çalışma prensibimiz şeydi:
Hayırseverle (boğazını temizliyor)
ihtiyacı olan okulu, ili
karşılaştırmak, biraraya getirmek ve
onların yatırım yapmasını
eeeee sağlamaktı.
Eğitimde çok ilginç olaylara sahne oldum.
Çok ilginç yaşantılarım oldu.
İlginç öğretmenlerle karşılaştım.
Tırnak içinde (imalı bir tonla)
ilginç öğretmenlerle de karşılaştım.
Bir gün Adıyaman Besni'den Saadet Hanım
Saadet Tabakçı, şimdi Tarsus'ta öğretmen
bana birgün mail attı.
Çocukları Ankara'ya getireceğim
gezdireceğim
eeee işte yol paramız
yok, kalıcak yerimiz yok.
Ben hem Turgut Özakman'ı falan tanırım,
onun hikâyelerini okuttum çocuklara.
Parayı da siz verin diyor.
Ben de bakanlıkta çalışırken
maillere dönerdim.
Hemen cevap verir
ondan sonra (boğazını temizliyor)
mümkün olursa da insanlara şaşırtmayı
sürpriz yapmayı da severdim.
Bir kısmı inanmıyordu.
"Ya oldu oldu sen genel müdürsen
bende Cumhurbaşkanıyım."
"Beni niye arıyorsun? " falan
diyenler de oluyordu.
Saadet Hanım'a da şey yazdım:
Kimleri tanıyorsan parayı onlar versin.
En alt cümleye de kaç para istiyorsun
diye yazdım.
Garibim çok bir para da istemiyordu.
1200 lira falandı. Parayı gönderdim.
Çocuklara hediyeler falan ayarladım.
İşte ziyaretler falan.
Çok başarılı farklı öğretmenlerdi.
Bizde eğitim acaba nereye gidiyor?
Ne yapıyoruz?
Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı sürekli
reform yapıyor biliyorsunuz.
Her gün reform reform reform
hatta reformun hatırına
reform sürekli gündemimizde.
Bu tür haberleri hep duyuyorsunuz.
Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı
orta öğretime geçişle ilgili
yeni sınav sistemini açıkladı.
Bu sistemin, adaleti
ve eşitliği sağlayacağı,
dershanelere olan talebi azaltacağını
ve öğretmen otoritesini
güçlendireceği, falan diye
yüzlerce reforma bence
şahitlik etmişsinizdir.
Şöyle bir hatırlarsanız geçmişi
hepimizin hayatında bu tür reformlar var.
Ben diyorum ki
nefes alalım.
Şu reform işini falan bir bırakalım.
Bu eğitim işini de biraz
İsmet Bey de konuştu,
çocuğa göre biraz yeniden
ele almak gerekiyor.
Benim üç tane çocuğum var.
Kızlarım kitap gibiydi.
Bütün okulları başarılı
bir şekilde bitirdiler.
Eee burs aldılar. İşte Bilkent 'ten
mezun oldu ikisi de.
Fakat bir de oğlum var. Bu okulun
ve eğitimin faydalı olacağına inanmıyordu.
Lise 1'de okula gitmeyeceğim dedi.
Oğlum diyorum bak ayıp oluyor.
Baban eğitimci, annen eğitimci.
Sen okula gitmezsen kim gidecek?
Yapma. Bak okula gitmezsen
üniversiteye gidemezsin.
Diplomayı nereden alacaksın falan.
Diplomayı dedi açık liseden alacağım dedi.
Eeee peki okulun entelektüel sermayesi
sohbet ediyorsun,
konuşuyorsun falan.
Ya baba be adamı güldürme diyor.
Sermaye falan yok diyor.
Genellikle okulda bize hakaret etmek
için devletin resmi elemanları var.
Bunlar bağırıp çağırıyor.
Ben dedi okula gitmeyeceğim.
Peki ne yapacaksın gitmeyeceksin (de)?
İnternetten dedi Oscar almış 100 film
indirdim dedi.
Ölmeden önce izlenecek
100 film diye de arşivledim.
Bunları izleyeceğim dedi.
Gerçekten öyle yaptı. Açık liseye gitti
ve bunu niye anlatıyorum
aslında eğitimin önemini
bahsedeceğim yerde.
(Gülüyor) Şöyle bence eğitim
anlayışımızı değiştirmek gerekiyor.
Bizim Hacettepeliler
bir eğitim tanımı yapmış;
Bireyin istendik davranışını
değiştirmek diye.
Ya kime göre değiştireceğiz?
Otorite figürleri her gün değişiyor
ve çocukların kafası dönüyor.
Şuna göre değiştireyim,
buna göre değiştireyim.
Ona benzeyeyim,
buna benzeyeyim.
ama kimseye benzemiyor.
Oysa eğitim insanların problem görme
ve çözme kapasitesini geliştirmektir.
Eğitim insanları yaratıcı kılmaktır.
O zaman arkamıza yaslanalım
şu soruyu soralım:
Ya bizim eğitim sistemimiz bireylerin
yaratıcılığını ortaya çıkarıyor mu?
Bizim insanlarımızı farklılaştırıyor mu?
Yeni bir perspektif, bir heyecan, cesaret
veriyor mu diye hep beraber
düşünmemiz gerekiyor.
Şimdi, ben ülkemizdeki
eğitim meselesinin
biraz zihniyet meselesi
olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Ya bir zihniyet sorunu yaşıyoruz.
Hep beraber bir bakış açısı
sorunu yaşıyoruz.
Bir tane doktora öğrencim
bir takım metinler getirdi bana.
Okumam için falan.
Ben de beğenmedim,
dedim ki olmamış dedim.
Hocam dedi hepsini
İngilizce'den çevirdim dedi.
Bu memlekette İngilizce bilimsel,
Arapça kutsal sanınıyor.
Ya Arapça her metin kutsal,
İngilizce her metin bilimseldir.
Yani İngilizce bir şey okursanız
kesin bilimseldir.
Sanki Arapların moda dergisi falan yoktur,
onların her metni de kutsaldır.
Yani sorun biraz zihniyet sorunu,
ve bizim öğrenciye dokunacak,
onu farklılaştıracak
öğretmenlere ihtiyacımız var.
Ben ilkokulu bir köyde bitirdim.
Benim ilkokul öğretmenim öğretmendi.
Ve okulda 20-30 tane
kitaplık kulübümüz vardı.
Bütün kitapları okumuştum.
Fakat bu bize diyordu ki o zaman
hatırlayanlarınız olacaktır.
Eee kese kağıtları vardı ve kese kağıtları
gazetelerden yapılırdı.
Bunların hepsini de okurduk biz.
Benim ilk okulumdaki sınıfımdan
5 tane üniversite mezunu var,
ve çok farklı yerlere
geldiler bu çocuklar.
Bizim köy de E-5 (karayolu)e yakın
bu bildiğiniz Adana- Ankara yolu üzerinde.
Biz yola çıkar arabalardan
gazete isterdik. Gazete gazete diye.
Gazete atarlar, bunları okurduk.
Bunu sağlayan kimdi? Öğretmenimizdi.
Bir şeyi okumak bizim için bir zevkti.
Zevk için okuyorduk.
Yani eski gazeteyi okusan ne olur
okumasan ne olur, ama okuyorduk.
Hoşumuza gidiyordu,
ve bunu paylaşıyorduk.
Bizim bu tür öğretmenlere
ihtiyacımız var.
Ben geçen sene üniversiteye kızıyorum,
ben zaman zaman kızınca istifa ediyorum.
bu özelliğimi biliyorlar.
(Gülüyor) Bir defa istifa ettim,
Kırgizistan'a gittim.
Bir iki yıl çalıştım. Hoş bir dönemdi.
Geçen sene de yine kızdım, emekliye
ayrıldım bu sefer. Kıbrıs' a gittim.
Kıbrıs' ta bir fakültede
dekanlık yapıyorum.
Bir gün dediler ki öğrencilere eğitim
ve kariyerle ilgili bir konuşma yap.
Olur dedim yapayım.
Güzel de bir sunu hazırladım
Eğitim ve Kariyer diye.
Sonra aklıma geldi salonda çocuklar,
salon dolu falan.
Kıbrıs'ta da bilenler bilir,
üç tane kale vardır;
Kantara, Sentileryum ve Profenda.
diye üç tane kale var.
Dedimki bu üç tane kaleye gidenler
el kaldırsın. 5-6 kişi el kaldırdı.
Ya kaç yıldır buradasınız?
4 yıldır, 5 yıldır buradasınız.
Küçük bir adada yaşıyorsunuz
ve üç tane kaleye gitmemişsiniz.
Kusura bakmayın ama dedim
bu beş kişi dışında gerisi çıksın,
benim size söyleyecek sözüm yok.
Ve ben sizi işe de almam.
Ya benim şirketime gelseniz,
Kıbrıs' ta okudum deseniz
ve üç kaleyi görmemiş adamı kesinlikle
notları 100 100 100 olsa almam.
Eğitimde okulda öğrendiğiniz şeyler
kapalı uçlu sorulara cevap verir.
Hayat açık uçludur.
Okulu hayata açmak gerekiyor.
Açık uçlu sorulara cevap verecek
hale getirmek gerekiyor.
Nurettin Topçu diyor ki felsefesi
olmayan milletin mektebi olmaz diyor.
Mesela bizim mektebimizin
arkasında nasıl bir felsefe var?
Biz ne yapmak istiyoruz?
Bakın blim sanat merkezleri var değil mi?
Blim sanat merkezlerini düşünün
az önce benden önceki konuşması
Maker olan arkadaşın konuşmasını düşünün.
Bilim sanat merkezinde onlar var mı?
Eğitim sistemi genellikle terk edilmiş
duraklara gitmeyi seviyor.
Yani geçmiş, işe yaramaz kullanılmayacak
bilgileri çocuklara öğretmek için.
Hatta Lester Smith diye bir İngiliz
(boğazını temizliyor) dalga geçiyor;
Çocuk kafaları boştur tıka basa
doldur onu hem bilginin yoktur sonu.
Ve bilginin sonu yoksa
çocuklara ne öğreticez?
Nasıl öğretmeliyiz?
Ne yapmamız gerekiyor?
Peki 21.yüzyılda şunlar
aynı anlamları taşıyorlar mı?
Öğretmen, okul, öğrenci, müfredat
Kitap temelli,
Öğretmen merkezli,
kara tahta
tebeşir
dört duvar aynı anlama geliyor mu?
Kabul edelim gelmiyor.
Yeni bir durumla karşı karşıyayız.
Yeniden düşünmek ve yeni durumu
yorumlamak durumuyla karşı karşıyayız.
Okul ancak kendi içinden gelişir.
Okulu ancak içerden geliştirebilirsiniz.
Okul demek öğretmen demektir.
ve ancak eğitime yapılan yatırımlar
öğretmene yapılırsa fark sağlayabilir.
Fatih projesi açıklandığında
bana ne düşünüyorsun dediler.
Valla dedim bir Erzurum türküsü var:
"Dün gece bir yar hanesinde
yastığım bir taş idi.
Üstüm yağmur altım çamur
yine gönlüm hoş idi" demiş şair.
Benden Fatih Projesine selam olsun dedim.
(Gülüyor.)
Yani şimdi farklı şeyler
yapmak durumundayız.
Bunu yaparken de
dünyada neler olup bitiyor,
bizde neler olup bitiyor diye
bakmak durumundayız.
Peki şunlar aynı anlamları taşıyor mu?
Eskiden okul tek öğrenme yeriydi.
Öğretmen bilgiye sahip olan tek kişiydi.
Öğrenci pasif bir şekilde dinliyordu.
Ve anne baba bize ne diyordu?
"Eti senin, kemiği benim" diyordu.
Ben şeylere girmiyeceğim
x,y,z kuşağı.
Bunların özellikleri nedir, ne değildir
diye durmayacağım.
Ama şunu bilmemiz gerekiyor:
Okul eski okul değil.
Öğrenci eski öğrenci değil.
O zaman biz empati yapalım.
Soralım:
Çocuklara ne veriyoruz?
Gerçekten verdiğimiz şeyler
onların gerçek hayatta işine yarayacak mı?
Şartlar kötü diyorlar,
durum kötü.
Bu kadar mı kötü?
Bakın akıllı tahtasına.
Peki adalet, eşitlik.
Biz eşitliği tartışıyoruz,
adaleti öğrenemedik.
Herkese eşit davranırsanız
bu adil falan olmaz.
Peki niye herkese bedava
ders kitabı veriyoruz?
Ya Adana'dayız. Ali Sabancı' nın
çocuğunun parasını niye biz veriyoruz?
Bunun yanında okulun önünden
geçemeyecek çocuklar var.
Popülist eşitlikçi uygulamaları
terk etmek, gözden geçirmek gerekiyor.
Çocuklara bakarsanız onlar ne diyor?
Bu okul bitmez diyor.
Daha 15 sene var, aynı şeyleri
pişir pişir önüne koy diyorlar.
Bu resmi Beypazarı' nda çekmiştim.
Beypazarı'nda bir kent müzesi var,
yolunuz düşerse.
Cumhuriyetin ilk yıllarında
çekilmiş bir resim,
Cumhuriyetin öğretmen ve öğrencileri
Çocuğun gülüşü sussa cihanda,
Bir ölüm matemi çöker her şeye.
Çocuğa kim demiş küçük şeydir?
Bir çocuk belkide en büyük şeydir diyor.
Bir çocuk çok şey yapabilir.
Bir çocuk dünyayı değiştirebilir.
Çocuğa çocuk gibi davranmak gerekiyor.
Bunu ben yazmadım.
Bir Temel(bir fıkra karakteri) mektubu.
Bunu da okursam sanırım sürem
çoktan bitmiş olacak.
Trabzonlu Temel Ağa' nın
sevgili torunu Eda'ya verilen
ödev ile başı derttedir.
Eskişehir' e göç eden arkadaşı Niyazi'ye
başına gelenleri yazar.
(Karadeniz ağzıyla)
Hani benim küçük torun var ya.
Geçen akşam, geturdi
ödevini önüme koydi.
Bi yandan da ağlayı.
Dertlerini hep bağa açar.
Dedi ki; 'ha bunlari anliyamadum.
O yüzden da yapamadum.
Yarin ögretmen beni dövecek.'
Dedum ki; 'Aglama usağum,
bunun içun öğretmen
adam dövmez.
Şimdi oni çözeruk.' Ne mümkün
Niyazi gardaşum:
Bi tirenlan, bi otobos ayni
istasyondan kalkmişlar.
Tiren otobostan üçte bir
daha hızli gidiy.
Otobos iki yerde onbeşer
dakka istirahat vermiş.
Tiren da bi yerde durmiş,
20 dakka su almiş.
Otobos saatte
60 kilometro gidiymiş.
Tiren 5 saat sonra
gidecegi yere varmiş.
Otobos ise ne vakit
sonra oraya varacakmiş.
Oğraştum yapamadum.
Uşak ağlayı.
Derken bubasi geldi.
O da çözemedi.
Diyrum oğa ki, ' damat, senun taniduğun
tahsilli bi otobos şofori
var ise oğa soralim,
belki o pilebilur.
Yahutta sabah olsun ben uşagi
şoforler cemiyetine götüreyum.
Onlar arasinda belki
tirenle yariş etmiş
bi sofor vardur da
bize nasihat verur.
'Ha, piz bi yandan da
uşağa tireni tarif ediyruk.
Tiren görmemiş ki...
Ne anasi görmiş, ne bubasi.
Ben da bi tek askerlukte
Erzurum'dan Sivas'a gittiydum.
Neysa gardaşum, o gece çok kizdum.
Diyeceksun ki niye?
Uşak daha incir agacindan
duti ayiramay;
mezgiti gösteriyrum,
hamsi diy;
efendum, yumurtanun
fabrukada yapilduğuni sanıy.
Biz gelduk araba yariştiriyruk.
Yani efendi, otobos
saatinda varsa ne olur,
geç varsa ne olur?
Gurbetten yolci mi bekliysun?
Eğer varacaği saat onemliysa,
edersun yazihaneye bi telefon,
derler sağa otobosun ineceği zamani..
Bu kadarluk mesele içun
sabiyi subyani niye
telef edersun?
Uşakcuklarda şarki yok,
türki yok, oyun yok;
dayamiş matamatiği.
Ayuptur... diyor.
Ya biz çocuklara
gerçekten bir ayıp işliyoruz.
Ve devrin değiştiğinin
farkında değiliz.
Yani eğitimin öznesi değişti.
Yeni bir okul teorimiz,
anlayışımız yok, bunu
geliştirmek durumundayız.
Okullar ne yapıyor?
Okullar ne yapmak istiyor?
Okullar nereye gidiyor?
Artık öğretme devri bitti.
Öğrenme devri.
Herkesin öğrendiği, birlikte öğrendiği,
geliştiği bir devir.
Ve öğretmen, lider öğretmen
çocuklarda merak duygusunu
ateşleyen, tetikleyen,
onlarla birlikte düşünen
yapan ve açık uçlu
sorulara cevap arayan kişi.
Bakın Pisa sınavında
çocuklarımızın % 40'ı
okuduğunu anlamıyor.
Bu artık eğitim sorunu
olmaktan çıkmıştır.
Ulusal güvenlik sorunudur.
Ya bir ulusun eğer çocuklarının
% 40'ı okuduğunu
anlamıyorsa bundan daha
ciddi bir mesele olamaz.
Oturalım, ne yaptığımızı
hep beraber bir düşünelim.
Gerilmene gerek yok.
Bitiriyorum.(gülüyor)
Peki çok
teşekkürler.
(Alkış)